[Música]
a comienzos de 1905 El joven Albert
Einstein de casi 26 años se enfrentaba a
la vida como académico fracasado la
mayoría de los físicos de la época se
habían burlado de la idea de que este
insignificante funcionario pudiera
aportar mucho a la ciencia sin embargo
al año siguiente Einstein publicaría no
Uno no dos no tres sino cuatro trabajos
extraordinarios cada uno en un tema
diferente destinados a transformar
radicalmente nuestra comprensión del
universo el mito de que Einstein había
fracasado en matemáticas es solo un mito
él dominó el cálculo por su cuenta a los
15 años obtuvo buenos resultados en la
secundaria de Munich y en la politécnica
de Suiza donde estudió para enseñar
matemáticas y Física Pero saltarse las
clases para estar más en el laboratorio
y no Mostrar referencia a sus profesores
frustró su carrera prevista no lo
consideraron ni como asistente de
laboratorio tuvo que conformarse con un
trabajo en la oficina de patente Suiza
obtenido con la ayuda del padre de un
amigo aún trabajando seis días a la
semana Einstein se las arregló para
sacar algo de tiempo para la física
discutir el último trabajo con amigos
cercanos y publicar un par de trabajos
menores sorprendió en marzo de 1905
cuando presentó un documento con una
hipótesis impactante a pesar de décadas
de evidencia de que la luz era una onda
él propuso que podría ser una partícula
y mostró que fenómenos misteriosos tales
como el efecto fotoeléctrico podían
explicarse mediante su hipótesis la idea
fue ridiculizada pero él estaba 20 años
por delante de su tiempo la dualidad
onda partícula fue candidata a
convertirse en la piedra angular de la
Revolución cuántica en mayo Einstein
presentó un segundo documento que
abordaba la centenaria pregunta de si
realmente Existen los átomos Aunque
ciertas teorías se construyeron bajo la
idea de los átomos invisibles algunos
científicos todavía creían que eran una
ficción útil más que objetos físicos
reales pero Einstein demostró que el
comportamiento de las partículas
pequeñas que se mueven al azar alrededor
en un líquido el movimiento browniano se
podía predecir con precisión por las
colisiones de millones de átomos
invisibles los experimentos pronto
confirmaron el modelo de Einstein y los
escépticos atómicos tiraron la toalla el
tercer documento llegó en junio durante
mucho tiempo Einstein había tenido
problemas por una inconsistencia entre
dos principios fundamentales de la
física el bien establecido principio de
la relatividad que se remonta a Galileo
afirmaba que el movimiento absoluto no
podía definirse sin embargo la teoría
electromagnética También bien
establecida afirmó que sí existía
la discrepancia y la incapacidad para
resolverlo dejó a Einstein en un estado
de tensión psíquica pero un día de mayo
tras haber reflexionado sobre el
rompecabezas con su amigo Michelle beso
empezó a ver la luz
Einstein se dio cuenta de que la
contradicción se podría resolver si la
velocidad de la luz es lo que se
mantiene constante Mientras que el
tiempo y el espacio son relativos al
observador le tomó solo unas semanas
trabajar en los detalles y formular lo
que llegó a conocerse como la
relatividad especial la teoría no solo
destruyó la comprensión previa de la
realidad sino que también allanó el
camino para las tecnologías desde los
aceleradores de partículas hasta el GPS
se podría considerar suficiente pero en
septiembre llegó el cuarto artículo como
seguimiento al de la relatividad
especial
Einstein Había reflexionado algo más
acerca de su teoría y se dio cuenta de
que también implicaba que la masa y la
energía una sólida y la otra etérea eran
en realidad equivalentes y su relación
podría expresarse en lo que se
convertiría en la más famosa y
consecuente ecuación de la historia e
igual MC al cuadrado
Einstein no se convertiría en un icono
mundial hasta casi 15 años después fue
tras confirmar su teoría general de la
relatividad en 1919 Al medir la
curvatura de la luz de las estrellas
durante un eclipse solar que la prensa
lo convertiría en una celebridad pero
Incluso si hubiera desaparecido en la
oficina de patentes y no hubiera logrado
nada más después de 1905 esos cuatro
documentos de su año milagroso habrían
seguido siendo el estándar de oro del
Genio sorprendente inesperado
[Música]
sumérgete en la brillantemente de
Einstein con uno de sus experimentos de
pensamiento de más triste fama la
paradoja de los gemelos puede descifrar
la respuesta Póngase a prueba con este
video
[Música]